I'm not recommending
you cut school
to go to trunk shows
or fashion shows.
But I did a little bit of
that when I was younger too.
By sharing what I
know, I hope that it
will inspire you to create
and express yourself
through fashion.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
My grandmother would buy me
Vogue, French Vogue sometimes
if I was really lucky.
And I would just pour
over these images.
That was my first
introduction to fashion.
I'll be discussing things that
I wish I knew starting out.
The heart of my class is
sharing the technical process.
Once in a while it's a fabric
that inspires the dress.
And other times
it's the dress we
want to make that
inspires the fabric.
This is called intarsia when
the fabric is not appliqued.
It is actually pieced together,
almost like a jigsaw puzzle.
A nice juxtaposition, of
finishing something beautifully
and then leaving edges
of the fabric frayed.
The runway show is
very important to me.
You can transmit not only ideas
about texture and proportion
but also about
spirit and emotion.
I was brought into Louis
Vuitton to shake things up.
And it didn't always
sit well with the people
who were there before me.
A lot of the ideas that I
had early on I was told,
you can't put this
on the runway.
And it really was when I
stopped listening to everybody
and did what I thought
was right that I did
what I was brought in to do.
But I personally feel
good when I take a risk.
I'm proud of myself
when I take a chance.
I think you should too.
I hope you learn
fashion is not an art.
It's part of the art of living.
See what you really love.
Do what you feel you have
some kind of connection to.
Create your own voice, your
own vision, your own style.
Taking creative risks is
what fashion is about.
I'm Marc Jacobs, and
this is my MasterClass.